[Applause]
everybody in the uh
and the outside world out there they
crash real tight to the monitor and i
push my way through and there's this
like
just trying to watch this little uh
strange journey we took yeah and thanks
max for the
like the rebel thing my pleasure you
were
you got a royalty on that too yeah you
were with uh springsteen right
yes yeah my drummer also zachary was
also with springsteen not at the same
time as you
that's right anything beautifully there
was a drummer in the wings to replace
max if anything went wrong what has
wondered who that guy was
[Laughter]
sitting there comes along hopefully you
have the coolest hair in rock and roll
doesn't he have to he doesn't think so
the guy there
there's one guy in there no he thinks he
can do a little better because he has no
hair
he's looking for his moose right now
first of all congratulations
yeah yeah yeah uh congratulations the
the birthday concert i want to talk
about this your 50th birthday
yeah most people get a cake you know in
a dreary party
you have a madison square garden super
concert
that's on pay-per-view yeah this is when
you know you've made it when your
birthday is on p
as a pay-per-view event that's the sign
that you've actually accomplished
something
the garden thing meant a lot to me in a
way because when my first trip to
america in
71 i flew over especially to see the uh
comeback show of elvis
and it was on at the garden so uh we
share the same birthday so
you and elvis have the same birthday
yeah we yeah we were drinking buddies uh
way back i used to fly over to memphis
and we'd uh
you know go out for the night on the raz
big cadillac
cadillac is there any truth to any of
this
no i was just told that was true
i just had to ask it's such a cool image
you sent me a telegram once uh-huh
okay i understand you know
yeah now i'd believe nothing in fact
you're not david bowie
here hair comes right off the um
you know i want to ask you you know one
of the things you've done that's so
amazing when you think you've
reached this point in your career you've
managed to stay relevant
in music and it's probably through all
the different transformations you've
made
you know the different characters that
you've portrayed a few years ago i
joined relevance anonymous
we'd just sit and share our ideas and
uh and and everybody else would network
and uh
give us feedback and suggestions of how
we keep relevant
who didn't get into relevance
synonymously i'm gonna stop right there
yeah i want this to get real mean real
fast
uh i want to uh actually just just take
a brief
walk down uh memory lane but first of
all just to look at some of the
different characters
let's put these up because it's good to
refresh everybody's memory of course
there was the young david
this is who early on then there was uh
ziggy stardust of course
then there was the thin white duke of
course my personal favorite
and then there was a period there where
you were trying
different you were trying different
personas no no don't do this to me
no i don't know other people remember
this we reviewed this once in the show
but you were you were trying different
personas that i don't think quite had
the commercial appeal there was the
suave hunchback
do you remember this at all ernie
yeah there was uh the bucktooth wizard i
remember he was
and then this is strange your corn on
the cob period i found confusion
i don't know what
yeah that was your favorite the corn on
the cob yes yeah yeah you're free to use
any of these by the way if you want
very much um uh i don't know if this is
true but i love finding these things out
you actually when you were just starting
out you started in a mime troupe
yeah i we worked in a mine troupe there
were several mine troops in britain and
it turned into a kind of a war between
mine troops the
the war the mime wars of 1968
do you remember those paris things the
parish riots yes that wasn't that wasn't
actually a student socialist
thing it was actually it was the mime
wars of paris
and it was all these uh the mimes were
after jean jenner so that they could
do the first version of the maids
so though you're going to let me go with
this i'm going to let you go and go so
they'll run around eating each other
we're going to put priya pricks oh wait
slow down
struggling each other in silence yeah
were you were you actually in a mime
troupe
did you do the thing in the box you
never did the thing in the box i did the
thing in the box oh get out of here i
did that
we're gonna ask you to leave now if you
don't want us to do the thing in the box
do the things good
yes
i forgotten it if you forgot it yeah
okay
hey that was pretty good but you have to
make this face yeah
yes you legally do you're in a lot of
trouble uh
you did there was a there was a a a
piece on the pay-per-view show that i
that was quite visually interesting the
scary monsters thing this was with
yeah what was it is that puppet there's
a um a media artist in america that i
like very much called tony ausla
um it's it's interesting that in the 60s
all the painters and all the artists
were really well known like andy warhol
and i guess in the eight in the 80s it
was jeff coons and
julian schnabel but right now it's
almost impossible to think of a current
artist who's
a household name in in quite the same
way so i'm just that's just an aside
really conan we had a clip here do you
want to explain what
you want to show this clip here liz uh i
don't know if this needs setting up but
it's visually but just look at it okay
look at it
[Music]
that's disturbing
that was another precision that's going
to be your next persona is that what you
said a head getting stepped on
yeah we're just going to get one of uh
tony's uh models to actually do the
vocals and i'll be underneath on the
floor and the whole thing will work out
i wanted to ask you uh there was
something that they were playing here in
america
on mtv around the clock for a while and
it was
something i've always wondered about you
singing uh christmas songs with bing
crosby
yeah and this is something that i guess
you probably did in 76 sometime around
then
what was that like because it's such a
strange thing to look at you're you're
almost polar opposites in some way and
there you are together singing uh these
christmas songs
do you remember doing this and what it
was like i i remember
i remember doing it um the communication
factor was very strange if i
had more communication in a way with
tony astler's uh
dummies but it was that he didn't know
who i was
he couldn't remember my name um
and he just sat on the stall the whole
day i know i would
be how were you brought into him so it
wasn't him saying uh i love this uh
whole ziggy sardis thing i want to meet
this guy
he just loved the heroes period yeah
it was very influential he's a very big
uh he was he tried for months to get eno
to work with him on his next uh
on his next album i would love to find
those recordings
you